[Applause]
i just by the way gained two pounds and
i think i came up with at least a
working title for our restaurant called
get stuffed
yeah
that's pretty good that's it
workshop
um i couldn't be more serious about this
okay um it is time to put your knowledge
of the windy city to the test in a game
we're calling
shy town crown
[Applause]
okay see you baby
exactly but what's what fun is a game
without an opponent
and ike since you were born and raised
in chicago you'll be playing against not
one but two chicago residents
okay please welcome
jonathan taves and seth jones the
captain and defenseman of the chicago
blackhawks
hi guys
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us you
guys we're so excited
thanks for having us guys thank you for
having me
it's crazy i i was going to say jonathan
i came this close to wearing your jersey
for the taping today but i just i didn't
sure looks good good choice
thank you
let's get to it because you will both be
competing
um ike you're against jonathan and seth
and here's how it works you're going to
take turns answering questions and
whatever team gets the most correct
answers duh wins but whoever loses will
be featured on a billboard in chicago
proclaiming their love for the drew
barrymore show i'm
[Applause]
i'm like
i'm sorry and thank you
see it sounds like a win to me drew oh
god i think
i'm so relieved
okay well thank you for
playing along and it'll be a real honor
for our show whoever ends up winning so
best of luck to everybody our first
question is gonna go to ike ike
what is the new name of the sears tower
a franklin tower
b
william tower c
a t tower or d
willis tower
drew the answer even though i still call
it this year's tower is d
the willis
tower yes
all right that's one for ike okay number
two jonathan and seth how much does a
typical deep dish pizza weigh a
10 pounds b
eight pounds c
four pounds or d
one pound
i don't know i mean uh after you eat one
it's you feel like it's gotta be a ten
pounds but i think uh i i don't know
about jonesy i think we got to go c four
pounds what do you think
yep yeah i think i think four pounds
[Applause]
even know that
as a wild guess to be honest
that's a good guess
um okay for ike um we're actually gonna
hand you something uh right now okay
because it's gonna lead to the question
there you go
okay
now
there is a famous hot dog in chicago
portillo's i would love for you to take
a bite and tell us is this a real
portillos or a fake portillos
all right
[Laughter]
that is real portillos
[Applause]
[Music]
great job
okay this next question will come from
audrina bigus who is right here in our
audience um she's a chicago reporter
with our affiliate wbb abs
[Applause]
thank you so much so you guys there is a
billboard with drew on the line here so
let's get serious buckle in for jonathan
and seth the question is which of the
following was not invented in chicago
not is the key word here a
zipper
b
printer
c the ferris wheel or d
softball what's your answer
i'm not sure i want to win this anymore
i'm okay with the whole billboard
jonathan i think i think it's not ferris
wheel what's going on
for the billboard or the billboard come
on
audrina tell us what it was the answer
is the printer was not invented in
chicago
that was a tough one all right you guys
it's two to one and ike is winning ike
name the song that was recorded by the
chicago bears
charted the billboard 100 and was even
nominated for a grammy
the super bowl shuffle
[Applause]
oh dear ike oh you're in the lead okay
jonathan and seth which person of note
was born in chicago a vince vaughn b
mike mike ditka
c jennifer hudson
or d refrigerator perry
i'm
pretty
pretty sure it's jennifer hudson so i
think we should go with c
ding ding ding ding ding
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
ike
you won
that was our last question
and you won
but jonathan and seth i mean
you guys played so well and thank you so
much for playing and we will be in touch
we're gonna
take that billboard all the way we'll do
some fun social around it thank you so
much jonathan and seth thanks for having
us
[Applause]
and i can't wait to see you soon
i always just have the most fun hanging
out with you we need more food more
games more hangs
amen oh thank you so much ike
hilarious new show chicago party ant on
netflix is available now
[Music]
you